hello and welcome to The Economist ask
Simon mikeraboy head of economists radio
as part of our open future season we're
asking should Britain vote again on
brexit our guest is the former prime
minister who's a proponent for the
second vote on whether the United
Kingdom should or shouldn't leave the
European Union
he was the special representative of the
quartet of international powers seeking
a peace agreement between Israel and the
Palestinians
and he runs the Institute for Global
Change advocating for the benefits of
globalization he still finds himself
drawn into heated debate on his support
for the war in Iraq and its consequences
Tony Blair welcome to The Economist asks
thank you we're meeting very exciting
time in terms of British politics some
people think too exciting cause for a
second referendum on leaving the EU are
in the air just lay out your position on
that for me so I've said for quite some
time now there should be a another vote
which isn't a rerun by the way of the
2016 referendum it will be a judgment on
what we've learnt in the last two years
and how we resolve the essential dilemma
at the heart of the brexit negotiation
which is that if you want to stay close
to Europe after brexit you can end up in
some form of arrangement where you're
abiding by Europe's rules but you've
just lost your say over them in which
case the argument will be well what's
the point of leaving or alternatively
you're going to be where a lot of the
hardline breaks the tears want us which
is with a clean break brexit where you
get out of Europe out of its single
market and customs union structures in
which case you're going to do short term
at least possibly medium term possibly
long term damage to the economy in which
case the question is what's the price so
what's the point versus what's the price
leads you to a I think to a gridlock in
Parliament which I think you can see
increasingly happened and I've been
saying this now for over a year there is
not in my view a majority in parliament
for any one breaks it proposition so at
a certain point there is going to be no
recourse except to either have a general
which would be a mistake for the
conservative party of course do or to
say no we're gonna go back to the people
and give them the final judgement over
whether they prefer the deal that's
being offered to them or they prefer to
stay right let's get to what the
desirability if you like of this in a
moment but on practicality and you're a
good and skilled process politician from
where treason may is now we have this
gridlock in Parliament which doesn't
look like getting cleaned up she put
forward a deal said called checkers
steel has left both leave in remain in
Parliament very dissatisfied so what
would be the route to another that
referendum would it be to say we simply
can't find solution so we're going to
put through legislation for that and in
that case how does it fit around the
fixed terms Parliament acted and the
other the furniture if you like of our
democracy I mean I think once you end up
with a gridlock in Parliament so that
you can't get an agreement on what the
new relationship in Europe is and
Parliament can't agree then the obvious
thing is to send it back to the people
and say look you're gonna have to tell
us whether in the light of what's
happened in the last two years and where
we are in Parliament today you want to
proceed with brexit or you want to stay
and this is a judgment not the same as
the judgment made back in June 2016
where we no idea what the process would
involve and what was the final deal that
would come out of it this will be a very
simple thing which is to say do you want
to proceed in these circumstances or not
given that reason mate if she wanted to
would make that argument in Parliament
first of all she has to get you through
Parliament I don't I think once
Parliament is paralysed I don't see what
alternatives there I well there are
three actually you crash out without a
deal which would be I think a disaster
and I'm sure Parliament would not allow
that or alternatively you have a general
election and I cannot see the
circumstances in which the Conservative
Party would want to have a general
election around the brexit issue I mean
they got into enough trouble last year
doing that I don't think
I want to repeat that mistake and in any
event the logical thing is to say to the
people that you you gave the original
mandate to do brexit it's proved
impossible to get it breaks it that even
all the breaks adheres agree on in which
case you're gonna have to decide for us
which way you want to proceed now and
it's actually a very rational thing to
do and I know rationality is not much in
vogue in today's politics but it's a
completely rational way of dealing with
this issue because otherwise even the
brexit people can't agree as to what
breaks it means so how can you possibly
say they've mandated one form that
breaks it over another but let's look a
couple of challenges to that position
even assuming that the resume or we need
whoever was that was Prime Minister by
the time this happened came into force a
referendum was promised
it was held it was described by David
Cameron is a once-in-a-generation vote
you yourself
talked in the early 2000s about putting
the European question albeit it was old
constitutional change but you were
thinking of going to the country and
saying can you please make up your minds
how close you want to be to the EU or
you don't both of you flirted with the
idea of a referendum David Cameron went
ahead did he get it very wrong well it's
not I mean look I I think I was the only
person who actually made a speech on
Europe of any significance in the 2015
election saying well I thought a
referendum was a bad idea and that in
itself tells you something in the 2015
election which David Cameron one and one
with the majority in Europe wasn't
really much of an issue but anyway for
whatever reasons I understand the
reasons the referendum was was held
but the referendum was held as to
whether Britain should leave the
European Union the referendum that I was
positioning us to have over the
so-called Lisbon treaty was a referendum
about whether we changed the status quo
in order to get closer to Europe
so if the country had voted if we'd had
that referee we didn't need to miss
France and Holland said that they didn't
want this Constitution anyway but if we
voted and we voted no to that
the status quo carries on the problem
with this referendum is your
disentangling 45 years of membership of
the European Union in which particularly
economically we have become intertwined
with the continent of Europe in
commercial and trading terms and this is
the first time any modern developed
country has literally tried to
deliberate straighting system on this
scale given that virtually half our
traders with the European market so it's
a it's a world away different because
it's not a world way different from the
referendum that took place two years ago
in which people were asked to vote and
with about 1.1 million votes in it
decided to leave now what I don't hear
yeah a strong case of advocacy for the
position of a second vote but what I
wonder what your mind the status of that
referendum is or whether one in the way
that has been known done before the EU
we just ask and ask again to the
electorate's get it right no I don't
think that's what we're doing at all in
this instance back in June 2016 okay we
knew we were voting to leave the
European Union we didn't know what the
new relationship looked like what the
the next two years have taught us and
let's be clear everybody now knows more
about this issue than they did back into
2016 I know more about this issue that I
didn't do in 2016 I was prime minister
for 10 years so we now know that
disentangling ourselves from the single
market and the customs union is short
term painful breaks it was sold on the
basis you get an immediate boost of
money to the health service and that it
would be you know a relatively painless
idea to leave the European Union it's
now whatever else is clear and you know
I understand the long-term vision of
Britain leaving Europe and going its own
way but whatever else is the case short
term we now know one there's not more
money for the health service actually is
a 40 billion pound bill for leaving
secondly we've gone from being the
fastest growing economy in 37th the
slowest third our currency is down
substantially devalued
since the day after the referendum and
forth short term if you do a clean break
break Syd you're going to do economic
damage there's no no one can seriously
dispute that now you may decide as it's
not necessarily the worst thing that is
the worst we did need correction to is
that this was a correction not because
the market decided that the market
circumstances of the UK had changed in
an objective sense it was a devaluation
because of the markets belief that as a
result of breaks that we're going to be
poorer as a country in the long term so
this was a completely different this is
not like a normal market correction at
all this was a correction as a result of
a political act so the point is very
simple in the end what we have known
over these last two years and the
divisions as to what brings it type of
breaks that we want mean that you this
is the reason you've got paralysis in
Parliament we don't know which way we
want to go so the only way of resolving
it when you started this process with
the referendum is to go back to the
people and let them vote what's the
question for this referendum well that
is a good question in itself and it
could be one of two different things I
mean the most obvious thing frankly is
that it goes back to the people with if
there's no agreement as to what a soft
brakes it really means and I don't think
there is I think the obvious thing is to
go back with a simple referendum choice
which is staying possibly within a
reformed Europe by the way and we can
come to that in a moment or a clean
break breaks it which is what the main
people advocating breaks it really want
but you could have you could have a
different question which is you actually
have the soft brakes at option that
Theresa May is trying to put forward you
could have that's an alternative to or
some form of it I mean these are
questions that you can get to at a later
stage but but surely if you're
advocating for this but you doesn't know
what you want the vote to be all yeah no
you do know what the voter model it'll
be stay versus some form of of leave or
possibly an option as to which form of
leave you want but you know these are
things that are you suggesting a
multiple choice when you say
oh well you you might have three choices
you could have you could have a simple
choice between two alternatives so you
might have three but you can discuss at
the later time and by the way to you
what do you think that were you favorite
very I'm a multi-part Hans because I
think it I think it depends really if
you if you end up I think you know this
is obviously you you've got to see the
circumstances that you get to but I just
don't believe myself there's really any
feeling in the country for what is
called the soft breaks it in other words
you stay linked to Europe like Norway or
Switzerland in some relationship where
you are still abiding by Europe's rules
and you've lost your say over those
rules I I think the country will just
say well that's the worst of both worlds
very snows we the economists will find
more acceptable than others and Norway
is one that we've given a pretty fair
wind to because we think it does satisfy
the desire to be further away outer core
as we used to call it in in sort of EU
terms but still firmly linked into the
trading system and on from peaceable
terms with the EU what's so wrong with
that because I think if you're talking
about does that fulfill the Mandate of
2016 I think it's very hard to say that
really because you know you're you're
coming at this from a perfectly rational
point of view which is say that our
preference has stayed but the
second-best to stay is stay at least in
the economic structures I understand
that the problem is the case of the
brexit ears is that the reason they want
out of Europe is because of the rules
that you have to and the regulations you
have to apply that come from the single
market and from the fact you're in a
customs union with the rest of Europe
and therefore don't strike your own
trade deals so it's very hard to see how
you you square a soft brexit with the
the main case that these people make and
understand the reason they make it is
one of the myths we don't know when
people voted their vision for brexit we
don't know how many well I didn't many
soft I mean that's another way that you
could I agree and that's why I say to
you
you know you could make an argument that
you have three alternatives you know
stay soft or hard but like eggs yeah
what the stay version but I think it
depends I've got a feeling that in the
end this this this will clarify so that
if you reach paralysis so there's no
real agreement for any form that breaks
it in Parliament then I think people
will I think the British people in the
end will want to make the final say and
to make it in a clear direction and the
problem with this the soft briggsie as
I've said right from the very beginning
is that in the end what's the point of
Britain getting out of the political
structures of Europe and staying in the
economic structures with all the
obligations but without the seat at the
table I mean it's a crazy thing for the
country to do and so I understand from
the business point of view you know in
the Economist newspaper and so on I
completely get it that they say well
though it's better than the alternative
but I think as a political decision the
British people will feel well this is
just well I think it we haven't ruled
out a second vote at all it's really a
question of how you go through the
process do you look at soft brexit first
before you move to it let me to put you
on the spot me what would your date be
for this but can people who want
advocates of a second referendum by
yourself really ground for much longer
saying well we'd like it sometime we
will sort out the question a bit later
shouldn't you put your date forward and
your idea forward well by the way it's
not as driving this agenda I mean this
agenda is being driven by a government
in more chronic disarray of any
government have literally ever seen in
my lifetime in the Western world I was
say in a major developed country and but
there you can get to you may look you
may end up having to postpone article 50
you may end up being in that position
but the point is you know when people
say to me why don't you just get on with
it which is a very common thing you'll
hear amongst people when I say to them
is afraid I'm sorry this thing's too
complicated just to get on with it
because it won't be gone on with it
way because until you've resolved where
you're going to go in the fundamental
questions and frankly the government's
not you know the checkers statement was
an attempt to come down on the side of
staying close to Europe I mean we all
know how some sympathy with that yeah
now of course by the way let me make one
thing clear I think Teresa may is a
well-intentioned person I think she's
got the least enviable job in Western
politics today trying to steer her way
through this morass I have complete
sympathy for her at a personal level I
know how difficult it is to be Prime
Minister but the trouble is what she
wants won't work and it won't work
because there is no way of squaring this
circle there is no way of staying close
to Europe and being part of a
frictionless border with Europe and
going your own way with your own trade
rules
it just it's literally and every time
the government keeps saying well this is
what we want they describe it as a
policy it's not a policy it's just a
statement of incompatible objectives and
at some point and this checker statement
was an attempt really to pull her side
into it okay let's stay close to Europe
to minimize EQ if it was down to you
would you advocate for delaying article
50 not leaving the EU not yet moving
that leaving date in order to open up
the SEC if I was if I was Prime Minister
at the moment what I would do is say the
following we've had two years trying to
reach an agreement it's now absolutely
clear that the choice we face if we're
going to do breaks it is between a soft
brakes that keeps us close to Europe but
unfortunately it means that we have to
abide by Europe's rules and therefore
lose our say or alternatively we can do
a clean break but you've got to be very
clear here are the economic consequences
of doing that and I would say in these
circumstances because both of those
things aren't unpalatable for different
reasons
I think it's sensible we negotiate with
you
a different option which is Britain
staying in a Europe that also has to
reform has to reform around issues to do
with immigration and freedom of movement
it's nicely what was not happening and
precisely what the drift of the European
Union was not well this is I think what
the European Union is going to have to
do it knows itself now it's got a look
the European Union has got exactly the
same problem that Britain had in
relation to brexit which is around
immigration so the freedom of movement
commitment which angle Merkel and others
but particularly I think angler Merkel
sticks on she says it's fundamental she
says it's one reason she couldn't give
more leeway to David Cameron to to come
up with a more bespoke deal all on that
in the run-up to the referendum you
think that itself is in danger as a
European no I don't have a principle of
freedom movements in danger because the
principles perfectly sensible and by the
way most British people would support
the principle it's a question of how
it's implemented and for example
president macro on France is already
suggesting that there should be
provisions in Europe that prevent you
know the import of cheap labor in order
to undercut wages in the more wealthy
countries of the European Union yeah by
the way countries like Belgium insists
that once you come to Belgian if you're
another from another European country
you come to Belgium you haven't found a
job within two months they put you back
again I mean there are whole sorts of
ways we could deal with this and the
principle immigration problem by the way
in Britain and elsewhere is not really
from Europe it's from outside Europe so
I think there are two big questions that
I think will dominate Europe at the
moment one is immigration which is
exactly referal to the type of feeling
that gave rise to breaks it and the
second is the other unresolved question
in Europe which is how do you make sense
of the Europe in which the eurozone and
the countries in the single currency are
bound to integrate at a different rate
in a different way from the countries
outside so there's lots of different
issues that in a sense should according
to any sensible view of Europe given
what's been happening for
in the Italian election should result in
Europe reforming at the same time is
britain reconsidering and that would be
frankly the perfect way out of this last
point referendum do you not worry that
given the division in the countries it's
not going to be possible to satisfy
everyone or even perhaps a clear
majority on this issue that referendum -
and you are calling it a referendum now
not people's vote or any of that what
people's votes the same thing I mean
well a referendum sort of says go or
stay doesn't a vote can simply say we
don't like the deal there is a
difference I don't think that's just a
difference in the question
look there's at point-p treating people
like idiots it isn't a rerun of the June
2016 referendum but when do you call it
a people's vote or a referendum or a
clevis I always language the fact is
it's it's an acceptance that the
confusion is such you need to have a
final say given to the brief what would
you do in the event the final say went
against your position then is then it's
the end of it if the British people vote
for leave in circumstance again yeah
again where they know they now know
exactly what they're going to be getting
as a result of that we let that all the
experience of last company is that's an
end of it I mean I I've made this
absolutely clear in my view once you put
alongside leave it leaving the European
Union the actual alternative the new
relationship once that is a clear vote
and the British people then decide look
we've heard all the arguments we still
want to leave that's the end of it we
think this addition is for that second
argument and that would create would
actually lead you to more of even more
of a populist backlash a more proto
trumpian backlash you know then we have
already
I don't would say it's a it's a first of
all by the way the country there's no
way getting around this the country's
bitterly and deeply divided and it is
but I'm I'm a skeptic that if you go
back and say look in the light of what
we now know here's the choice and you
the people made the choice that people
are going to consider
an insult to be asked I don't think they
will let's talk more broadly about
Center politics in the guise of our open
future season which is looking at it
broadly at the future of liberalism and
and the the center you have stood for a
certain kind of Center politics very
electorally successful yourself in in
power for a long time in Britain and and
others in Europe Bill Clinton in in the
u.s. this feels like something that has
been not just under attack but has been
sort of crumbling with from within for
quite some time is central politics
dying reviving I don't think it's either
dying or reviving I think it's never
gone away I still think there's a
majority for it I think the macro
election in the sense is one indicator
of that but I think the way modern
politics works political parties can be
taken over by those from without outside
the center and then the choice for the
people I mean it the choice for the
British people is pretty grim if it's a
brexit dominated Tory Party versus a
Corbin led Labour Party yes sir I mean
that is a choice of two extreme
positions where I think the reserve and
majority of British people that would
not really want either of those two
things if they have an alternative which
would then be a case for electoral
reform voting system before and whether
it's voting system reform but it's it's
a question of I mean my preference is
the Labour Party sorts itself out but I
have to say that looks unlikely sorts
itself out as in returns to the
centigrade because Gary Corbett is
leader well look it's it's a question of
getting rid of them as leaders much more
fundamental than that it's a question of
whether the Labour Party understands
that it it won power I mean remember we
were in power as a Labour government for
more than twice as long as the next
Labour government ever we were the only
political party Labour Party to win two
consecutive terms never mind three
consecutive is this 1997 to 2000 yeah
and we did it from the centre but by the
way David Cameron
from the center in 2015 so it's not as
if this is you know politics that has
had its day and and you know one of the
fascinating things when you look at the
recent OECD report the country that did
best in terms of social mobility from
the late 1990s to 2010 the country that
did best of all the Western developed
countries was Britain and that was
because you had a progressive
center-left party that was keeping the
economy strong but nonetheless making
real social changes and this politics is
still the politics that I think it's a
combination of people who believe in a
strong enterprise sector believed deeply
in social justice are socially liberal
that is a constituency today that
probably is a new you know electoral
constituency and frankly at the moment
it's pretty much underrepresented they
do you think Jeremy Corbyn could win the
next election has your view changed on
the probability of that I think it's
look first of all you can't say anything
is not possible in politics today and
certainly I didn't I thought like the
work would get badly beaten at the last
general election now I think there were
many very special factors in that
election not least brexit the
conservative manifesto which was a sort
of disaster area and the way they fought
the campaign so I you know personally I
think with this government and this
disarray we should be 15 20 points ahead
we're not but who knows it's possible
yeah it's possible he becomes Prime
Minister and you know to the context
were speaking he now is just after
Helsinki and and that summit between
Donald Trump and that person do you
think actual harm has been done of that
some opinions divided on whether this
was just another trop show as usual or
whether you know whether you feel a real
harm is done to the security
architecture of the West
well I think
you know President Trump has his own way
of doing things for sure
and I think it's it's hard right now to
see exactly what the implications of it
are but my reflection is more to this
point that it shows why it's so
important today that Europe stays united
it's why brexit is not just an economic
disaster it's it's a geopolitical
disaster for Britain and for Europe and
it shows I'm afraid that in today's
world the interests of America may lie
elsewhere and I'm not sure this is
completely connected to Donald Trump by
the way I think for the moment for
whatever reasons America wants to look
after itself and its own interests it's
big focus is his relationship with China
this is the the America China
relationship will be the pivotal
geopolitical relationship of the 21st
century and I think my reflection is is
less to do with critiquing his position
because there are plenty of people who
can do that as well as I can it's really
to do with how Europe react and you know
right at this moment if Europe wants to
stay powerful it's gonna have to stay
united and strong economically and
politically and this is the tragedy of
what is happening in Europe at the
moment you know if your international
network how connected are you to the
trumpet team I think you met some of his
advisers you know III you know
particularly on the Middle East where I
remain very active on the
israeli-palestinian question I remain in
contact with them and you know I'm also
because of the work my name is Jared
Kushner
and with with other people in the team
there and you know I because I'm my
Institute is very active in Africa we've
got teams in 14 different countries
today and you know I'm active with
different parts of the American system
and I keep closely in contact with it
and you know I haven't been President
Trump himself but yeah of course I stink
would meet president Trump if the
occasion arose well if I had the right
thing to discuss and he wanted to it
would depend what the issue was but
Jared Kushner his designate to deal with
the Middle East is ISM selfing yeah in
the firing line over the Miller
investigation isn't here into the
backwash of the allegations of Russian
interference in the election and sort of
stringing pulling through the trunk
businesses yeah but you know for me the
important thing is if I'm working on the
israeli-palestinian issue in this these
are the people who are designated as
dealing with it it's important you keep
them comfortable and what difference you
think that the don't Trump being in the
White House and a shift on the way to
handle the Middle East has made to the
chances eautiful good or otherwise of
achieving anything in the Middle East in
terms of a deal so I think that that I
mean you know it's it's as I always say
to people as hard sometimes to have a
rational conversation about Trump's
policies because there's so much focus
on on the personality and the character
I think the one thing the administration
has correctly understood is the the
future to resolution for the Palestinian
issue lies in the israeli-arab
relationship and not simply in the
israeli-palestinian relationship I think
that they've understood correctly and
they've got immensely strong ties with
both the Israeli leadership and the Arab
leadership however I don't think you
will get a resolution of the Palestinian
question unless you build it from the
bottom up as much as trying to negotiate
it from the top down I think the
problems are deep politically and
economically between Israel and the
Palestinian territories and I could boil
you've endlessly on that but I don't
think we will get a resolution unless we
do it through the israeli-arab
relationship and by the way I think this
has to start and start urgently with
what is happening in Gaza which is a
catastrophe and extremely dangerous and
needs to be handled with
urgency you think we're looking towards
a person Netanyahu era now and did you
see any on and on the Israelis like that
you think might be able to take on that
process and I think it's far too early
to say that and you know Israeli
politics is a study all in itself but no
easier you know Bibi Netanyahu is there
and that's the prime minister that that
you know he's been there now for a
considerable period of time as huge
experience obviously and I don't think
there's an election in the offing so
we're sitting here in a different office
I think the one I visited you in last
time we spoke to you for the Economist
asks you've consolidated a lot of what
you do now into this Institute so the
global change you have cursed pretty
much all of your sort of consultancy
work is that a sign that there had been
a bit of Blair sprawl and you were doing
too much you know I tried to do
something since leaving office because
you know you're gonna find this with
prime ministers and the presidents who
leave office when they're relatively
young and the circumstances where
friendly people can remain healthy and
active much longer you know I was never
going to end up retiring as Prime
Minister than just going on the speaking
circuit so I have I built a whole series
of different organizations and then I
had a business side who I think I
explained to you in an interview we did
a few years back his purpose was always
in order to better fund the the
charitable work the so I made two
mistakes really first of all I think
having these different organizations in
retrospect and this would be my advice
to anyone else doing this put it all in
one Institute and we have this one
not-for-profit Institute now which is a
much much better way of doing the work
we do the Middle East and Africa around
governance counter extremism and
coexistence in this new part we're doing
which is about renewing the center
ground of politics in the West so it's
much better done as one institution and
secondly frankly people you know with
the business side you're always going to
get people who misunderstand your motors
or misters
and you just get into a run of trouble
over it so I think what we did was we
transferred what all the substantial
reserves we've built up in the business
side into the Institute that allowed us
to get these offices going and get
moving and now you know we've got around
about 250 people working for us in about
30 different countries the first easing
you I could say you kind of come around
to the view that we discussed then there
was a bit of a problem between the
balance of Mammon and good works in your
life and well it was it was more to do
with the way it was could be present or
misrepresented but but ya know III if I
was doing it again I'd set it up as it
is as it is now but you know no one's
ever tried to build an organization as a
former prime minister and the thing that
people have never understand is that you
stopped being Prime Minister right your
infrastructure goes everything goes and
you may have a name but you are nothing
else so you've got to go in fundraise
for it you've got to either make the
money or raise the money as a large
organization operates in many different
countries and it takes a lot to build
but the work we're doing here is is
really fantastic and I think in time we
will I hope we can lead to a shift of
global politics or help in a shift of
global politics back to support for what
I call the open-minded view of the world
the international liberal order and the
politics that says globalization is
actually basically a good thing but you
need to deal with its risks in order to
access its opportunities you're 65 now
only 65 I should say really because
there's a bit quite a long time since
you were Prime Minister and you've done
a lot of sense but it is a good time to
to look back and did you what do you
regret um well I was think one of the
interesting thing is is you go you stop
being Primus you go out into the world
and you learn an immense amount so I
have learned a huge amount in the last
10 years about how the world works which
you just you know if you're in politics
especially I came in 1997 I never been a
minister before your Prime Minister
ten years you learn a huge amount so
there are things that I can regret and
domestic policy around reform I think
the biggest regret post 9/11 was
misunderstanding the depth of the
problem of sort of radical Islamist
influences and therefore when we we
thought when we changed regimes in
Afghanistan there are gave the people
the chance to improve their lives then
surely this would work but there were
many forces that were trying to disrupt
at us they still are today but you know
I also look back on the things that we
did that are on the more positive side
the big changes in society that we
introduced in the UK you know the
radical reductions of poverty the
improvements in schools and hospitals
the minimum wage the Northern Ireland
peace process bringing the Olympics to
the UK I mean there's a lot that we can
be proud of as well as obviously I don't
think anyone's in power for 10 years
without there being things that people
disagree with certainly Blair thank you
very much for joining the economist
tasks this week thank you
you